I think I read this somewhere that you
wrote something like 20 to 30 drafts of
this script what is the biggest
difference between draft one and what we
see in the final film Nuance writing
specifically for actors whom I've cast I
generally write with actors in mind I
wrote Crazy Heart
for Jeff Bridges wrote out of the
furnace and hostiles for Christian and
then once you find your Edgar Allan Poe
and you find your captain Hitchcock and
superintendent Thayer and the rest of
the cast and when Jillian Anderson comes
on you you tend to have to to tailor
them so so the outline was the same it's
all then about characterization and then
really quite honestly it's about honing
pose themes that then course through the
film because this is really an Edgar
Allan Poe origin story
so you have to have the themes that
ultimately
influence this young unformed writer to
become the writer he became with what
you just mentioned of all of the
characters you cast here which role
changed the most after you filled it and
then who changed the lease where they
just happened to meld perfectly with
what you would well I would say Poe
changed the most
um only because we have very entrenched
ideas about who Edgar Allan Poe was and
that's from later in life people found
when he died under mysterious
circumstances in in Baltimore and was
prone to alcoholism and it left us as
the creator of detective in horror
fiction but this is about who he was
before so it was really about
understanding Harry's tone his
performance trying to find somebody
who's warm and humorous and witty and
prone to to romantic and poetic musings
and then having Harry Express that and
bring that to life and I would say that
Augustus Landor uh played by Christian
Bale change the least because he's
he's uh quite recessive and quite
understated and a keen Observer and
changes uh he changes quite a lot in the
film he goes through a great deal
emotionally but you see that only in an
incremental uh moments I thought you
were going to say because you had
Christian in mind for the longest well
and also because Christian was was with
me through every draft how about
production wise now is there anything
you accomplish in this movie that maybe
would make like first feature Crazy
Heart making you go like damn I can't
believe that I would be capable of
making that happen well being able to
take something that's kind of Epic in
sweep an emotional scope shooting in
minus eight minus four degrees I just
wasn't prepared as the first time
filmmaker who was making a very intimate
uh musical drama
uh and then making the films that I've
made since that are much more epic in
scope uh that require a lot more actors
that require shooting and uh
inhospitable and kind of brutal
Landscapes and locations
um pretty much all of it quite frankly
what about like the smallest possible
detail like you were just mentioning the
tree like something along those lines
something that might not necessarily wow
audiences when they watch the movie
about what it took to actually find that
thing this tree that's over my right
shoulder that that sits alongside the
river it took forever to find and no
tree was just right if you see how this
Branch just happens to extend out in a
very parallel Fashion To The Ground
you'll see that that plays an important
part so no detail is too small and there
are many details that I can't quite give
away for fear of perhaps spoiling
something but every costume in the film
was handmade whether all of the cadet
uniforms uh everything that Christian
wore Jillian Anderson Senator Lucy
Boynton and on and on and on and I
really couldn't have done it without the
United States military Academy's help
and their technical assistance is this
the most difficult movie that you've
ever made
had to talk about without spoiling
anything no question yes because
everything leads up to the denouement to
the final uh scene in the film and we
all know that that in the film business
that endings are the most important
thing because that's what you leave the
audience with it's their parting moments
and hopefully everything that you're
building
really kind of culminates in those final
moments and this is a film that I think
personally requires careful viewing and
actually maybe all the Richer upon a
second viewing here's a difficult
question to answer without talking
spoilers but given that and given the
re-watchability of the film even as the
Director and the writer the person at
the helm of all this is there anything
that you saw one of your cast members do
in the edit that made you think like I
didn't even see that on set and it
enhances the scene more than I can
imagine yeah well so often you you you
see that with actors in a particular it
happened frequently with both Christian
Bale and Harry melling because their
performances are so different as I
mentioned Christians is quite restrained
and observant and and and he isn't
giving anything whereas uh Harry
melling's portrayal which is very
accurate is is uh Larger than Life
almost and quite poetic and exuberant
um and then you would see moments that
if I'm standing next to the lens that
I'm not looking at a monitor in that
they play beautifully but then in The
Cutting Room and I think oh my God I
didn't see that moment and in particular
I would say Christian's performance is
incredibly delicate and
as the writer and director I'm
withholding information from the
audience about his past we understand
the very opening moments this is a man
who has suffered loss and that's parsed
out
um intermittently and that hopefully all
comes together in the end of the film to
make sense it does make a whole lot of
sense Christian's performance is
beautiful I will say I think my single
favorite word delivered on screen in
2022 23 is books books nothings I must
have rewound that a million times just
because I wanted to soak in the joy in
him when he expressed well young Edgar
Allan Poe in a library full of books for
someone who's influenced by writers and
Byron whom he's whom he cites moments
later was one of Poe's favorite writers
I love that moment so much speaking of
Harry now he's delivered some
exceptional work over the years but this
might be one of my favorite performances
of him and I just have this feeling like
he's gonna break out in the biggest
possible way so what is something about
him as a lead actor in your film and as
a collaborator that you're really
excited for more directors out there to
get to experience well I sure hope so
I'd only seen his work as the limbless
performer that Liam Neeson carries
around the American West and the Coen
Brothers Ballad of Buster Scruggs that
was the only thing I'd seen of Harry's
and he is remarkable he's for me
personally a revelation in this film
maybe less so for you because you've
seen such great work of his in the past
but he has such range he has such a
compelling and interesting look that can
play both contemporary and play very
beautifully uh in a in a very period
sense obviously in 1830 or in the cohens
which is probably in the 1880s or 1890s
but he is a remarkable actor with so
much range and he's the nicest guy and I
really hope that people see this film
and in particular I hope directors and
Studios see this and say I want him in
my film I love the sound of that I'll be
rooting for that I'll be rooting for
people to re-watch this movie over and
over to enjoy all the details I mean it
I mean it